the word crowd-funding is a compound
word there are two words in that word
and the first word is not there because
it's a prettier word it's there because
it's the more important word yeah I just
can't stress it enough that you know it
really especially when comes to
crowdfunding it all comes down to
relationships and it all comes down to
building those relationships and keeping
those relationships I'm not saying you
need millions of people but you need an
AK or group of people because those are
the ones who are gonna help you to
spread out you're not gonna be able to
spread word of mouth all by yourself
we're all encouraged in our life that we
can do whatever we want that we are
entitled to achieve our dreams and we
can do this and we can do that and with
crowdfunding it's you know people think
that oh well now that's that's the
answer to my question I just put my
project up there and since I'm entitled
to have a dream I'm entitled to write a
book or make a movie or be a ballet
dancer or put on my theater production
that people now are going to give me
money
we shot she's gonna have it in 1985 we
would do on Kickstarter for that was
Kickstarter we just had the technology
generating a fanbase there's no that's
that's the question I've never solved
the generating a fanbase question and
never would have launched a campaign for
six figures if I hadn't spent two years
building an online audience with a
website the way you structure your
campaign is how your will largely
determine how you're seeing whether
you're successful or not I certainly
know when I've been on the other side of
the crowdfunding thing it's been quite
tempting to think you know Wow could be
part of this movie and the guy's not
famous or anything but maybe it'll be a
successful me then I'll have been part
of it I try my hardest to try to stay
connected online whatever with people
that are really reaching out to me you
know I don't see why we shouldn't be
it's really surprising that no one gets
back to you so it is a race you know
your crowdfunding is like a real amazing
time where it's just like there's you
can't think about anything other than
getting the word out and like you know
making an update video and up posting
you know new things and getting people
interested in like trying to get film
blogs to talk about it I think one of
the really lucky things about our
project is that we had sort of the tiny
house community there you know ready to
kind of help us get the word out not
having a good pitch video to me I feel
like is the ones I've seen I'm like and
I would never donate to that because the
video wasn't good whether it was a
production value or just the pitch
wasn't good and I just didn't feel like
it was a compelling enough story put a
couple months in on on the video and
part of it
one thing I recognized with Kickstarter
that was very very clear is that you
have to have the personal touch I would
not have had a successful Kickstarter
campaign we would've had a successful
Kickstarter campaign if we weren't truly
100% passionate about the film we
researched a lot of campaigns we've
probably looked at about a hundred
different campaigns you watched all the
videos or looked at their rewards the
perk structure all the texts on the
actual Kickstarter page sometimes you
get discouraged Wow
I just send in like a thousand email I
mean it's still not moving
I mean okay I think for short films and
books and albums and any other thing
that is below 30,000 it's great over
that you're gonna have a hard time you
might be lucky but you know one of one
out of thousands can be successful and
the rest fail does get people involved
and creates an audience that wants to
see your movie and that's invaluable but
there's you know I guess what I would
say is none of these things come without
you don't gain something without giving
something now that's one of those cases
where our entire momentum went back to
zero and it was very hard not just to
start up from that point but to start
off from a really really low point well
I think any pursuit that you do in life
is filled with failures and successes
and you often learn more from your
failures than your success so you know
of course you have to pick yourself up
what else you're gonna lie in the dirt
the rest of your life it's not an option